okay welcome welcome everybody good to
see that we still get some attendance
even though the food's not here
hopefully to return at some point
anyways so welcome to our usual Thursday
research conference I see a few faces of
people I don't know that's always a good
thing and this particular conference is
a PhD dissertation proposal defense in
our program as most of you know in order
to move on to actually do your
dissertation you need to defend your
plan in public and that's what ISA my
Ari is going to do today and so I will
introduce him I don't want to take a lot
of his time he'll give a talk and then
we can ask questions challenge him
whatever so ISA has been in our program
for I guess since 2013 he has his BS in
biology and chemistry from Portland
State and received a master's in
biochemistry and molecular biology here
from OHSU he worked in the lab of the
famous dr. Lewis picker who is
developing HIV vaccine and other things
and for his dissertation he's focusing
on a current computational bottleneck
for robust identification of rare
cellular subsets so thank you dr. Hirsch
and thank you everyone for being here
this is a exceptional time for me as a
checkpoint to my career so and in this
career degree I'm getting and so I want
to quickly just give you guys a
background about what I'm trying to do
and so that because it's a
multidisciplinary topic I'll be going
through several different domains and
topics rather over the top and so I just
want to make sure that we stay on the
message
and the point is that the rare cellular
subsets when you have a homogeneous mix
and there are some populations of them
that are very rare relative infrequency
that are deterministic for health or
action or they're actionable for health
care and so that's where the thing I'm
proposing a computational tool that
we'll get at those rare cellular subsets
however those regular subset could be
spread around in multiple domains of
biology and we'll get into that but in
the end my proposal is within
computational biology and it's proposing
to look at a computational framework in
a way to be able to analyze but various
biological deal and as a motivational
case I want to bring about two causative
agency pathogens that I've worked with
so far in my career
HIV microbe active tuberculosis together
in the 2015 they killed three million
people worldwide and there are there are
even complications where they both of
those are combined however although
there are treatments and there although
there are potential vaccines they're not
effective these diseases
change over time if you don't take the
drugs right and therefore we meet these
are important challenges currently and
ideally kind of where we're going with
this is being able to identify these
protective cellular immune or phenotypes
that I could that are potentially rare a
lot of times in the immune system and
therefore being able to vaccinate
someone in this and this window of
opportunity where these protective
immune or phenotypes are working and
hopefully they'll not cause this like on
this unvaccinated person or persons have
a high viral load which eventually
listed by day 56 but but they hundred
and beyond they'll it will come back up
and go towards eight but the goal is to
be protective and so that's why they
will cellular I mean the phenotypes
sometimes they are important so what am
I talking about single cells
what does it mean and when I'm looking
at
cells and in majority and since this
comes from the immunology world it's a
pointed basic picture of a t-cell but in
an idea you have the nuclear envelope or
the size of the the cytoplasm or the
membrane up there and so there are
proteins or markers or sugars or some
stuff that are spread out we identify as
markers that we can tag using antibodies
specifically to them those antibodies
could have a floor or a metal bead and
the mask can identify that specific
antibody binds down to that marker of
interest and in a way we can get
single-cell resolution of specific
targets so that we can identify who or
what this cell is and what function it
and as you can imagine another general
example these accumulate and it's not
just one molecule of list of it's in 3d
right so on the surface there's many of
these proteins expressed and as a
combination of all of them it defines
again who this cell and what its
function is traditionally full of
saitama ters even ologists cancer
biologists when they look at Seiler
subsets they use flow cytometry using
the antibody method that i talked about
and they look at these pairwise gating
systems that they drill down on so the
first screen they see for example is
they get on t-cells which is used by 33
markers they get out for example
negative gate out specific types of T
cells they don't want so these are gamma
delta T cells we don't want them so we
take the little or and so forth until we
get to the population that we want and
you can imagine as we're drilling down
into these populations the downstream
it's rare and rare and less and less
frequent and and that's one of their
challenges and you can easily imagine
where you place these gates upstream
affects the population you choose
downstream and how is this used if this
data is used one way is used is to look
at the frequency of a new amino
phenotype that's important it's
protective or not so let's say in the no
protection group it's higher than the
protection group
can insinuate that that correlates with
no perfection
on the other hand we can think of as a
single markers expression like let's say
proliferation like Kasich is seven where
we're looking at specifically with like
let's say that cells proliferating and
we look at that markers expression so in
those two ways are the majority of the
ways we're looking at it there there are
other ways but the majority of the ways
we look at flow data is least two and
again we're looking at in immunology
infectious diseases which so we're
looking at these protective amedeo
phenotypes and when I'm talking about a
rare cellular subset I'm talking about
imagine if you know up there 50/50 like
one to one and we're talking about rare
being less than 10% in general of a
total heterogeneous mix mix and again
you can imagine stem cell biology and
Falls even to farther down here where
the stem cells are even less frequent
and potentially some of the
immunophenotype that were interested in
and as well in cancers like circulating
blood cells or even also those cancer
seizing simple they're also very rare
and therefore we need to think about if
they're actionable so safe can be
prognostic diagnostic or therapeutic
phenotypes within that and in fact it's
a hallmark of the adaptive immune system
to be creating this heterogeneous subset
to create this rare cellular subsets
that identify specific catheters and
that's how we can protect that cell and
in it adaptive immune systems evolution
is for this purpose is because this
plethora of stuff out there how do you
get at and so the adapter system works
kind of in cancer is the same thing
heterogeneity is one of those major
hallmarks and it being rare subsets at
different time points across the tumor
for example can be indicative actionable
in terms of part gnostic diagnostic or
therapeutic and so sometimes identifying
even Eraser early in time could be
targets to go for diagnostic or
therapeutic effects so uh clinically
actual
so now that I've described how their
volumes are important how we look at
them computationally what are what are
we doing and there's three major things
and the one is to be able to classify
those cells robustly and reproducibly to
be able to identify clinical correlates
and to visualize the phenotypic
landscape as a whole those are the three
tasks we're doing and in this proposal
I'm specifying the darker focusing
mostly on the top part the top one but
the the other two must also be part of
the idea in the back of our heads where
we're thinking about the bigger picture
and in the end we're doing these
comparative phenotyping to understand
this amino pathophysiology of the what
we're looking at so to that note of
computationally being able to analyze
flow data the oil back there was a flow
cap data set challenge number one which
was targeting at specifically
classifying similar phenotypes and in
that challenge there is the the results
majority showed that computational
methods are much better than any human
method they reduce the variance analysis
and even if those sensor is a sensor for
doing a task rather than individuals
doing so even the superhuman training is
less causing more variance than
computational and computational most
important is reproducible but it's
harder to reproduce something a human do
and in general one of the things that
they report on is is using an F measure
which I'll get into a little later but f
measure has a range of 0 to 1 and not
pinpoint 9 is pretty high up there and
so they're happy with it but in flow cat
1 they weren't looking at rare cellular
subsets so come so cat 3 because once we
have a good foundation for
computationally looking at things well
what are the bottlenecks and look at 3
had a challenge specifically looking at
rare cellular subsets and on average the
two populations that they have for us to
work with are on about 0.02 percent and
point oh four percents
of the total heterogeneous mix and in
this dataset they're looking at T cells
that are stimulated using HIV proteins
in an assay where you put in the
antigens and the T cells pass a certain
amount of time they accumulate the
cytokines they need and that's blocked
so they don't release it and so then
those cells a pass through foresight
ammeter and then you know which cell
detected the antigen and thus responded
with the cytokine they're rare because
that antigen that is detecting is in a
way being detected by a very rare so
your phenotype as a whole and matching
that sequence so that's the cell type
we're interested in as a as a
classification challenge going to this
proposal and it is important for us to
to consider when we're looking at
something like the rare cellular subset
the technical variability and biological
variability that heavily confounded and
either batch reagents one lab could use
one antibody that I showed earlier
another bad lab use another lab antibody
that could cause a difference in that
definition of that sub time we're
looking at and the SOPs and the
instrumentation because could be
different as well as the various
biological variability and some of the
even general demographics like gender
and an H and this is the F measure I
could I put in here so we can quickly
just talk about it f measure is a
harmonic mean of precision and recall
and if you're more remember recall is
simply how many of them do we predict
and precision is simply how many of them
did we predict correctly and so with
this as I said the ranges between zero
and one that's where that's the
measurement we're going to be using but
not as a whole but specifically looking
at those rare cellular substances so on
slow cap data number three which focuses
on rare cellular subsets there was a the
top-performing algorithm was done by
pink we in 2015
I got an S measure of 0.69 the model
breaks down into three parts and I'll
briefly explained its parts but in
general
there is a training part where you have
some training data and the data that I
had that means it has the gold standard
it's been gated it's clean and
everything and so the machine learning
algorithm has to learn from it and then
you have your test data which you bring
in and you're asking it it's not labeled
and you're asking it to predict on and
and the way they approach it is through
an ensemble majority vote which it means
and I'll get a little deeper water what
the SVM is doing but imagine it as just
a single classification model for each
one and if you do it 50 times and you're
getting this vote of is this a rare
failure subset or not and you get the
majority vote that's the way they
approach and a quick definition for what
the support vector machine is because
that's the model they use is that a
support vector machine is a algorithm or
machine learning for a Freyja framework
we're trying to find a hyperplane or a
line that completely separates the two
classes that maximizes their separation
and so here to the example and the pink
line in a way is trying to split the two
and in a more realistic case I have a
little toy example here in a 3d and
these are the same they're just
rotations of one another and so you can
see if I draw a hyperplane not all the
subsets if get it in like to be on the
positive side of that happen some is
left behind and so that's one of it
limitations of drawing a straight line
when you're trying to gate and that
parallels what we're doing what the
manual getting worse because in a way
that was also a straight line in many
cases it needs more of a curved line or
a angled life and so if you imagine in
this figure that all of those hyper
planes from the 50 on ensemble training
to trains that are put together on a new
data set so each of them will be
chopping at different angles and even he
has a mean like the yellow one is the
mean of them all you can imagine that
it's not doing the best job and I'll
have another picture that shows that but
that's kind of like
for you to visualize how that this
system is not the most perfect way of
classifying these cellular subsets and
and the ensemble method how it can have
issues with not always getting all of
them and the other part is that the
supervised machine learning method you
see this is a underlying the support
vector machine is a supervised method
and that means it's learning everything
that it's seeing of that dataset so when
it's trying to insert on a new dataset
it's assuming it's coming from the same
mathematical properties the same types
of data set and so forth so that's why
if there are let's say batch effects
realistically the supervised models
learning the batch rather than the
actual signal you're interested in so
that's another limitation the the way
they focus on rare cellular subsets when
they have for their support vector
machines because generally support
vector machines aren't good at getting
rare so your subset if they have
employed a down sampling mechanism where
basically down sampling brings about a
more balanced classes so the more rare
population in the end and this for
example if you think about in terms of
probability of being the rare failure
subset and this is the density of the
entire dataset this bump represents
there are cells of interest the rare
ones as opposed to these ones and this
is based on some probability of being a
rare so your subset and they choose the
top 20 and in a way they're kind of
focusing on the back side which is more
focused on the rare Seiler subset that's
how they're doing they're down sampling
and kind of removing the effects of the
larger populations in the dataset but as
I said there could be batch effects that
they're learning and to solve that
problem they're using a Hellinger
divergence and if it's visual I put in
so that imagine if you have a new test
data and you just put here and ideas
what are the most closest data sets that
I can train on that potentially don't
have that batch effect so if you train
on maybe V 3 and you want to infer on
this side potentially that's too far
away and
you're learning on batch where is the
idea of this using this optimization
you're getting potentially at the closer
ones thus eliminating some of those
issues issues with pageant palace so
anyways as I said there are several
limitations so the linear SVM rate cut
the class imbalance and the fact that
down sampling could add its own bias and
the fact that the similarity based
ranking is not a perfect solution to the
fact that there's batch effects and
there's other issues and we just are
finding the most similar datasets to
train on it's a nice approach but it's
not the solution and kind of my proposal
to solve some of these bottlenecks and
still limitations in identifying rare
cellular subsets is using transfer
learning the transfer learning is
different than supervised learning that
they use in transfer learning the
assumption isn't in the training set
which is the new data set that you get
it does not need to come from the same
mathematical domain or the same data
source and therefore it can make the
inference on such a new data and so but
the the base of the model as I shall
show here there's some training involved
and then there's some inference in law
and lay it out in 2012 developed a
transfer learning algorithm for flow
cytometry announced however their focus
was a different setup that it was a
larger saw subset it wasn't as high
dimensional as we're looking at today
and so part of the thing that we are
part of the motivation for going beyond
this is going to higher dimensions going
on bigger files and at the same time
focusing on some of the limitations that
were going to be addressed by transfer
learning and the just a brief overview
of the lead-out transfer learning
approach is that again there's some
training involved and from the training
there's multiple SCM train which very
yield that
average hyperplane that I showed but
just that's just the concept so as a
concept it's learned the idea of a
harder plane of a mean where it can be
and so now when you give it a new test
data it's not just inferring that
directly on that data based on its
previous training it's looking at the
data that is being trained on I'm sorry
it being tested on directly to find the
best place the low-density solution here
so in a way it learns the idea I need to
put in line but then it doesn't infer
like that it transfers that idea to the
new data set so it's directly making
that discrimination value put on the
data set so that that does a better job
of just looking at doing and inferring
with a supervised method and to show you
visually what that means is that this is
a again a toy data and here this type of
line kind of like is going up that way
is the mean of my training set and so
you can see it's cutting through the
blue dots that I care about
whereas once I've trained once I
transferred the the hyperplane to the
optimal place it's more cutting the blue
ones that I want sure it's not perfect
because those two problems are very
close to each other their effect size is
small and so so therefore aside but at
the same time you're still cutting the
the line at a better place than it was
originally and kind of where that comes
from
is that there's two parts to it there's
a bias shift and a rotation of the
hyperplane and so if you imagine like a
samurai chopping across this data set
and then once is finding the optimal
rotator bias shift is finding the
optimal rotation and if you do this
iteratively back and forth you find the
most optimal place
so comparing the two methods between
queer dolls and Leah Dell is that they
had a support vector machine model with
an ensemble and the core of the transfer
learning is also a support vector
machine because it's doing that same
hyperplane prediction but it's any
chance for learning framework so it's
not doing direct inference like
supervised mess currently the lead owl
method does not have a are speed
optimization and that's something that I
have to focus on potentially the first
strategy is to use similar way that they
created out use however there's several
different ones that we can explore and
find the best one and that makes sense
for our case and at the same time
there's no need for doing a Hellinger
divergence like they do because our
child learning frameworks solve that
problem so we only need two so that's
the part that is in our advanced as a as
an addition thing to add to our model
we're going to add a confounder
corrected SVM which means that we're
trying to eliminate the effects of
confounder variants on the outcome and
in a way if you think about it if your
training on let's say a bunch of data
that came from women and then you try to
infer on the data that came from a man
potentially that could work there may
not and so these confounders could have
an effect on our inference and so we
need to account for them and so the real
signal some is partly affected by other
confounding factors are the various
things so that's something that we'll
put into our model so specific aim one
so develop a transfer learning flow
cytometry currently framework to
identify these rare cellular subsets
such as amino phenotypes while
evaluating and minimizing the variance
to batch confounding factors covariance
and non-linearity of the distribution
boundaries so like I said if it's
nonlinear you can probably catch more of
them but at the same time you can
imagine that complexity issues
and so we have to balance those two
together and also there's also concepts
of dimensionless dimensionality
reduction where you reduce the hyper the
high dimensionality of data sets and
you're trying to look for them in a low
dimensional space the simplest one will
be in PC a more complicated one being PC
but at the same time there are other
opportunities for search potentially out
of scope for this proposal but still a
lot of area to investigate to kind of
give you guys a picture of what the
framework will look like so as I said
we'll have the full cup data three data
sets to build this framework and also
some simulated data sets and we'll have
some meta data file like the confounding
factors platform gender or so forth and
at main FCS files and there will be some
learning part of the chance in the
transfer learning and of course some
inference and what we'll get out is
these cellular populations that we
trained on whatever it was and we'll get
some central tendency some frequency and
some information about the model fitness
and parameters so give us some
confidence in our prediction and so
forth and the most important thing is
like why are we doing this it's like
once we have these rare Slater subsets
cated and potentially they could be
correlated to disease and being like
these protective immune phenotypes that
I for example talked about or actionable
phenotype in cancer we I really have to
map them to these five conceptual
dimensions of phenomics where we've
defined them in a way with this method
of flow cytometry analysis and in a way
the idea of what that what they mean and
the cause of that information behind
them came from acquiring the data and
other than order a priori on what the
immunising types defined each the
representation is something that for
example ontology is how phenotypes are
computationally structured and
represented because as just text they
they're meaningless so I can call them a
cd4 memory cell but some potentially
that means nothing and their
interoperability like once we find these
immuno phenotypes that are important
maybe I'm studying in the rhesus model
and I want to be able to bring it into
the human model and so this
interoperability is important as well
and finally processing
that what are we going to do the end
goal like it's a kitty Ellen outfit is
it just doing correlation with clinical
data whatever it is we have to be
conscious of the utility or the
processing of the of the phenotypes or
universes that we find through our rare
so yourself and as a case example I want
to focus on a specific group of rare so
yourself like old mates or because we
associate invariant T cells which are
type of T cells there which are gained
to wiser critical in a second but just
as a whole in adults they represent
somewhere between one to ten percent in
the blood and in the newborn court blood
there's somewhere between 1% and lower
and and that creates a challenge if
we're trying to identify them in one
tissue versus the other so if if I train
on one data set most supervised learning
methods will fail at doing this because
it's a completely different domain but
that's the beauty of transfer learning
is that the hope would be able to learn
on one domain and infer on the other one
despite the difference and as I promised
quick information why we care about
these mazes why they're important as the
majority of the lab that studies are
sitting right over there is that these
cells are restricted by a unique antigen
presenting cells different that they're
the ones that classical T cells are M R
one is a molecule that relatively non
polymorphic across different species in
animals which means that they're
representing or presenting these
antigens that are common across the
species potentially at least bicycles
that's one key thing in human was they
be shown if they detect microorganisms
such as MTV they respond into MTV and
therefore they're happy they have been
studied for their roles in early mucosal
immunity and they they exist in life
from early on in newborns to adult life
and in fact that where we look at we're
looking at newborn cord blood data and
so another most important thing about
them is this innate functional capacity
just unlike any other T so that requires
training in
assignments and that up selection and
down selection that they go through
these cells don't need that sort of a
training or selection in a way they are
functional when you get them from a
infant from the thymus
and wherever you find them you put them
in a culture they'll respond to energy
and so that's another unique property
about them which goes back to thinking
about their role in early mucosal
immunity especially earlier in life and
why are they you know infants for
example get more infectious such
pulmonary factors such as T V versus
adult less so they're less likely to
accomplish anyway so towards that
specific aim to identify specific mate
cells into diverging developmentally
associated tissues PBMCs coming from
blood and from blood of adults and cord
blood cells from newborns and so we want
to look at these meet cells in within
our framework so I first classify them
and then to be able to think drill down
once we've classified them - to
understand the biology and what's
different and kind of to give you a
visual of what we're expecting is that
there are a bunch of these additional
markers that are indicative of their
developmental stage their function and
so forth so once we can identify them in
the cross the two datasets
we can then study their biology and
their role in protective immunity and
just general health at immunity and the
picture I showed earlier was HIV vaccine
that kind of is projected and this is
kind of adapted to be for TV but because
TV has this kind of a reactivation so
forth but the idea is the same by
studying these immune subsets that are
important to protection we want to
create a vaccine that gives you either
sterile or complete protection and
that's the the whole point of it at
least in immunology what I'm returning
to work with their loans in lab is to be
able to contribute to finding and
understanding these immunity no tests
that are potentially important in
protective immunity and going to the
future and kind of out of the scope of
this proposal I'm making currently is
that once we've developed our kind of
like our framework to study
rare special subset is within the
transfer learning framework there are
other ways of like improving and
thinking about that we can take the
direction of trying to answer research
or clinical need and either the model
can be improved we as I said the
optimization for our peers can be
improved and at the same time we can
expand into several different ways of
the rotation and the shift by a shift
that I thought about there's other ways
trying to do that as well so that's kind
of where where we can go into there
beyond and and so with that I want to
jump give my acknowledgments to my
mentors a lot of names under this but my
thing I want to really thank dr. McQueen
D and dr. Lorenson and Mario was not in
the room today as well as my
dissertation committee and all the other
people who really helped me get it to
this point
thank you very much is incredible and if
I forgot someone I apologize but I try
to include all those I immediately
remembered but but thank you I
appreciate I'll take any questions you
guys put your turn to grill me I know I
talked about last time I'm not doing so
come back go ahead Josh
Queen
they did cite that paper but their point
going forward is that this letter
potentially is more optimized there's
three faster but in terms of like coming
to biology there has not been shown a
method that compares this method to that
method directly using this standard data
set and kind of what I'm trying to show
is the first step is that if so is this
transfer learning because in theory
sounds better not just for batch effects
but just for the fact that we can infer
on a new data set that came from
anywhere that kind of has the same cell
types of interest that way we can
potentially be beneficial no matter what
and we'll compare it to the same data
set and we'll see how well it performs
but kind of the first time
in short is doing a gradient descent to
find out the minima that best cuts the
slice in the high dimension and then so
the in general is doing one is doing a
projection of the the new dataset into
the direction of the kernel density
estimate of the training and so that way
you kind of get you're in the same
trajectory and therefore you can make
the inference in the same kind of logic
and so you find the the the lower points
of the minima in that regard and that's
kind of weird and the same iteration
you're finding the rotation as well
besides the vise right
yes in a way partially I think that the
new dataset has to be not be completely
random right but you have to have the
same in a way concept of being able to
find that population but in in its
theory it's the whole idea is to be able
to put the new dataset within the same
projection of the old training that you
have so that they're similar in terms of
your the transference anime so because
yeah yes yes and I think that the trick
is I think if you imagine in high
dimensional space like even in the data
sets they're not necessary because of
the batch because of whatever they're
not necessarily aligned these in in high
dimensions they want to be completely
aligned so we have to somehow the new
datasets realign to the the training set
and that is done through kind of
geometric math but
right in a way it's kind of like yeah I
defined the the normal vector to that
bias the mean that I find that kind of
creates the vector trajectory where I'm
doing the Tobias shift and once I find
the right place there it's doing their
rotation from that so it's kind of like
an iterative process it does not it
doesn't come to like a one go then it
come to a single answer
in the
in the domain of transfer learning there
are several different cases SVM is one
of the most common ones but know you can
pretty much use several different kinds
there they get more complicated I think
like imagine trying to transfer more
curvier shape geometric shape as opposed
to a straight line it makes it more
difficult in the case that I'm proposing
yet but I would like to investigate the
non-linearity but with the limitation of
it's causing complexity and therefore
losing meaning translation and at some
time adding time or without a handle
well I mean that kind of out of scope
not going to talk a little far out on
that so the idea of why for example this
could be better is I think I left for
another talk actually will not talk
about industry but there potentially the
only thing that made you think that this
will solve I think as opposed set is
over there with defining is maybe these
hyperplane and over here with defining
multiple hyperplane in circuitry method
and so hopefully and so that's why
potentially I could be beneficial and
some studies when they compare the two
get better but it's not guaranteed for
rare sites or subsets so that's
something we have to investigate if we
go down that path
because the um I actually don't I don't
have a biological answer to why that
could be better because they're
hierarchal immune soul subset okay okay
thank you
yeah absolutely and the the that's why I
think that there was a potentially good
work but they haven't been looked at and
they're currently will be further
downstream of what I'll try to do into
this proposal but it potentially I agree
it is well depends how I define V F you
can say the F of the act in the for the
real failure subset not as a comes as a
whole but but the way they've defined it
in the folk at one data is looking at
the whole as kind of like an average of
at all but when I have to present it I
have to look at an F measure of the
specifically getting at the rare figure
subset but there is a another version of
it that specifically balances the
precision versus recall just has like a
1 minus beta thing next but nonetheless
it you can balance which one you want a
favor is it more recall or precision but
I think that in terms of being able to
get at a direct comparison the F measure
will be a good comparison to you
so that that's why we can balance it but
I don't wanna I didn't propose it
directly because that's not that won't
be a direct comparison to what's already
in that because I want to compare to
create URLs paper because that's the
data set we're using and everything but
yeah I mean if we are trying to tune it
to potentially other start describing
the bridge we can use other ways of
looking at it
what do you mean like their their model
mmm I mean I I'm not creating that the
the create out framework on but on my
friend oh this offer no no I don't have
access to the I have access to the flu
cap data and therefore that's why
sticking with the f measure where at
least get me close as close as possible
without having this exactly
but that's not going to stop me from
thinking it a better thing that I think
is better and writing it they all this
is a better measure but you know that's
just for downstream here for evaluation
exactly okay fair point
exactly so I'm not trying to beat them
at their actually I'm trying to be the
most accurately picking out the relative
subsets of interest and being able to
think correct for some of the variants
that confounders and so forth so they
can I have a clean robust reproducible
outcome in the end that's their goal and
beating their score is a bonus so yeah
um your data is a more of a kind of
classification in the bucket so it's not
a rank kind of output is it okay because
I mean if it were ranked and you know
there's all kinds of measures you know
that combined recall and precision but
but if it's if it is a classification in
the buckets and that wouldn't work but
if you did have a task that were ranked
in output you know that there are plenty
of measures that that use recall and
precision and combine them and you know
that taking your counselor as you go
down the ranking yes absolutely but
again I couldn't be tight as puzzle to
be consistent but I would love to go
further on these things and investigate
afterwards getting the PhD so forth I
mean there's a whole domain of transfer
learning that I can keep expanding in
China tuned to clinical needs and
research
I'd hold it hold it so you saw half a
kind of a question for ASCII what you
mean by a confounder you know that is is
that something you have to predefined or
is that something that will fall out of
your analysis as you compare different
data sets yeah in the low cap data that
I have the contenders are gender age
platform of the mix I thought for flow
fluorescence low and I think those are
the three major ones that I have the
most robust data for but I haven't done
an exported data analysis on that day
like ozone we have access to yet but yet
in general that's kind of like I would
imagine as much as metadata we can
collect we can put in the confounders
that's why early on we will talk about
getting asked of clinical data from you
but it you know since that goes limited
with our data set as much as I can get
from the flow cap I'll put it in and
I've looked at the algorithm at simplest
form is a matter of zero one like this
is like let's say female male sub like
that and that is very broadly looking at
some of those confounders but but again
it can go deep drill down further
depending on what we collect so
hopefully we can in the future collect
data with good metadata all right
another question about evaluation at the
beginning of the talk you mentioned that
for the more frequent cell populations
computational methods are as good or
better than manual gating do you have a
sense of how well your other than will
have to be to match manual gating for
the rare cellular receptive is there
more variation and how people manually
gate for those I don't have a feeling
for it just yet because I don't have I
haven't run real data in my in the
framework death but I do think that the
variation in the data sets will be sold
by the properties of transfer learning
like for example if you're trained
has some noise it's still getting at a
very general hyperplane from it and then
transferring that to the data set so to
then test that so if I mess on your
question right your your concern is
about if the data training set add too
much variance is that right well so I I
just meant R is there more disagreement
among people when they be gating for
rare cellular sub test and then there
been there is for more frequent oh I see
absolutely absolutely thank you yeah
yeah okay absolutely that humans oh it
could we make as much mistakes you know
when we're trying to make not equally
come I mean compared to computational
methods because these resources are hard
humans are not are not it's not easy
task for humans either so but it's not
equally as variance as the more dominant
population as I showed that early slide
we were looking at those big publishers
easy to draw the boundary where then
then the smaller populations then it's
more of a cloud nebulas cloud that's
hard to find the boundary for and so
absolutely the difficulty comes thank
you from there
yeah like no more questions
um could you speak a little bit about I
know you kind of mention already just a
little bit more about why you decided
assume it's mostly just like a
complexity issue of not choosing a
nonlinear approach I took the linear
approach as the first half to compare
with the tweeted out because they also
have a linear SVM but I would like to
explore the non-linearity I just don't
know how much that will give us
I definitely in how I see them and the
populations in that high dimension space
not being always linear but at the same
time if we they're separable enough a
linear bound you should be good enough
right so the question is so making sure
our input data is clean so output is
also clean in other part
I guess we'll wrap it up with that thank
you very much for attending and
listening
[Applause]
you